cotton candy who knew sugar and air
could taste so sweet
well a guy named James Marcin an amateur
inventor whose occupation and taste buds
didn't exactly aligned he was a dentist
and during his lifetime James even
became the president of the Tennessee
Dental Association don't forget to floss
but he was also a confectionery
enthusiast with a passion for culinary
advancement he paired with John C
Wharton an old friend and fellow
confectioner together the two designed
incur patented what they called the
electronic candy machine the device
rapidly spun and melted sugar through
small holes until it was fluffy at
nearly 70% air they called the Nutri
fairy floss they introduced their
product at the 1904 World's Fair selling
it in small wooden boxes for 25 cents
each that's about six dollars today
fairy floss was a huge success in six
months they sold over 68,000 boxes
grossing in today's money around four
hundred and forty thousand dollars but
despite the success of the sugar spun
business Marcin returned to his day job
as a dentist so next time the dentist
tells you you're eating too many sugary
treats well blame him
you